SCP-682 Vs SCP-101.
Could the Hungry Bag finally be the anomaly
that doesn’t find the Hard to Destroy Reptile
too tough to swallow?
SCP-101, the Hungry Bag, is a small, tooth-lined
bag seemingly connected to a limitless pocket
dimension, capable of devouring almost anything.
Dr. Lee Roy Carlson suggested it might be
perfect to finish off 682 after it was reduced
in size by another anomaly.
So after SCP-682 was shrunk
down by a confrontation
with SCP-165-1, its tiny body was thrown into
the gaping maw of SCP-101, and swallowed up.
Later, however, SCP-101 began to gurgle for
an extended period.
After a prolonged period of discomfort, it
belched up the tiny SCP-682, which later returned
to its normal size.